China Taiwan and the 550 billion dollar
industry that underpins all of our Tech
what's going on
I'm talking about semiconductors we
again found themselves at the heart of
geopolitical turmoil in October it
started with the U.S massively
restricting the ability of Chinese chip
makers to buy technology abroad
particularly the gear they need to make
the chips themselves yes semiconductors
helped run our iPhones and cars but
they're also used in missile systems and
Next Generation fighter jets at the
moment China has to import most of its
chips many from Taiwan the island just
100 miles off the Chinese Mainland has
its own democratically elected
government and considers itself an
independent nation but China and its
leader Xi Jinping don't
and at the Communist Party Congress in
Beijing she raised the temperature on
the possibility of seizing Taiwan but
what would that mean for the chipmakers
feeding Taiwanese chipmaker tsmc has
warned that should China try to take it
by force it will not be able to continue
operations normally because it needs
support from our foreign suppliers
company Executives have said that they
are more concerned with other human
calls that the war might inflict that's
one reason why the U.S just allocated 50
billion dollars to bolster its domestic
chip making capabilities to reduce its
own dependence on Taiwan and other
nations I'm Alex Webb and this is the
upload follow us on your favorite
platforms
[Music]